when you did Letterman Letterman was
called the David Letterman show yeah at
the time and you sort of became sort of
friendly with him
David Letterman shy was working with his
dogs so he got my name oh here's how
David Letterman got my name I believe I
forget how I still have the t-shirt that
you say David Letterman it was a Morning
Show and he had a little jazz band in
the back and we got to know each other
really well Fay and I would hang out we
go out to the Hamptons with him and his
girlfriend at the time Meryl Marco uh we
became friendly in fact a couple of
times he was hosting the Tonight Show
they flew me in to be a guest with his
on The Tonight Show
um trained his dog's Bob and Stan then
you drive around in his duster he wanted
to buy my dude and he would try to get
on my case to buy my duster over and
over again but I wasn't I wasn't selling
it does he was a really neat guy Dave
was kind of interesting quiet a nice guy
and then the funny part is when I
started working with him uh later on he
was doing he was doing the Late Night
show and I was working with his dog by
the way I was training all the dogs for
Saturday Night Live at that point if you
saw a dog or a cat or a horse on
Saturday Night Live I was there Denise
my wife were just talking about it
um I did a segment with uh
um Glenn Close where she was playing a
dog show a dog show judge where the show
goes wrong so I had all these dogs
around her she's standing on the podium
as the judge and all the dogs attacked
her it was a great great scene um so I
got to work with all of them you know
I'm going back to uh the Bellucci days
all these people so every week I was and
it was a pain in the ass show to do
because I have to go there and and be
there Friday and be there Saturday
morning then have address rehearsal see
what they're going to put on what
they're not going to put on wasn't there
some SNL actor who thought he was being
upstaged by the animals and got upset
I'm not going to mention his name uh
John uh what the hell is his last name
Belushi no not John Belushi oh God candy
no yeah he wasn't on there he wasn't
yeah that's the ticket
oh yeah yeah that's the ticket yeah uh
oh God yeah he's actually you know he's
a nice guy yeah I'm friendly with him
but he was a little he goes I don't want
these dab stage he was doing a segment I
think it was with Dana Cartman I don't
remember and it was a segment they were
had this there was a bloodhound involved
bloodhound's a beautiful dog man they
were being upstaged by the blunt neither
one of them are attractive looking guys
the dogs have staged them and they were
pissed off they cut the dog I still got
paid but they cut the dog and then for
the Letterman show we did the suit of
suet where we addressed David Letterman
in the suit of suet and I put deer and
raccoons and possums in a cage with them
and none of them would go near him
really because they kept the suit in the
uh in the commissary at NBC and the food
sucks at the commissary it probably
smelled so bad that the animal said you
know what I'm not going near it the
character was Tommy Flanagan yeah that's
the ticket yeah yeah me and my wife
Morgan Fairchild whom I've seen naked
yeah
um wow I mean all the stuff you've done
it's crazy I remember I saw you on
Letterman one night
and you brought a pig on set
to the Letterman show and David looks it
and goes uh wow Lauren uh where does
this pic come from where did you get
this pig and and you said oh I you know
I just actually got it uh tonight um you
know here in Manhattan on the streets
goes where he goes where do you get a
pig you know what I think we all know
where to get a pig at this hour
he he would drive me crazy he said I
picked smart so I went out and I
literally bought this pig for 35 and the
day before I did the show with Dave I
spent the night with the pig training it
working with it so I get some response
on the show didn't work out no he didn't
work out too great but anyway the pig's
name was spotty black and white Pig so I
bought I bought him on the show and
they've had this whole thing with him
but then I had spent the night with the
pig I can't bring him back to the farmer
I kept him now I had the pig on Long
Island in Oceanside my hometown
for like eight months and he kept
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
people would say to me what I said some
red dog from hungry
and then and that's when that's when
Fang and I ultimately we had to buy this
Farm can you imagine buying five acres
with a house and a barn on it for twenty
nine thousand dollars can you imagine
this slum I lived in I mean they have to
go outside to pump the water how many
animals lived in that farm I had rescued
30 dogs at that point 27 cats six
chickens six Ducks two pet pigs Corky
and spotty twenty Parts
you know what and yeah but every one of
these animals God I loved every yeah I
think I get tears when I think about
some